congratulations on the movie thank you
it's a wonderful performance for you you
had to act very sick at certain points
and and deal with all the things that
are going on in your character's life
what was the biggest challenge for you
did you find one part of it was more
challenging than the rest well for me
then the emotional scenes weren't the
hardest for me to get in that kind of
feel for it I had to think of a part
where I was really sad or maybe another
time when I was really sick kind of
reconnect with that yes find it for your
performance I think I mean the first
thing was you know we're tackling the
movie with kids you know there's a
couple things that I tried to do I knew
I wanted to tell a story about a
relationship of the kid who evolves I
love films that have transformations and
have arcs with the character you can
really clearly see from the first scene
to the last scene is completely
different so I love the idea of a
mystery of a person like a young kid who
believes that no one would help and
feels like if you do everything by
himself and he's so isolated so with
that being said I knew I knew I needed
an actor who can really bring everything
through the eyes to the performance and
and be able to understand the subtext
behind the scenes so when doing a kid
film there's two things that I was able
to think about it sometimes with kids
films that sometimes the body language
of kids and how they move around is
there's no focus there sometimes the
performance because of the tone it can
be kind of corny or it could be one way
or another and I know this was an adult
film where kids can build a brace so I
knew I had to have the right actors you
know so right off the bat I was able to
see a short film that Skyland did where
he played a character that didn't really
say anything but one word in that short
film called Duff that I really liked and
I just thought he was pretty amazing in
that same audition room Pete came in on
that same day when we had auditions they
didn't know each other so they came in
and immediately I put them together for
chemistry and they had immediate
chemistry where Skyland character mister
was always about what's not being said
and keeping things inside where Pete at
the same time was a subservient to to
Mister so
you had all this with less dialogue so a
lot of that was just breaking down and
being native were from Los Angeles is
being going to New York we spent a lot
of time talking to kids that were in
this situation kids they were left alone
or sometimes a mom would be able to go
away for a little while or be in
addiction programs or just sometimes
leave and they'll be left with friends
or to be left with grandmother's or
neighbors so we've met a lot of kids in
Red Hook projects in Red Hook project
and on East Brooklyn and we spent a lot
of time with some kids in Marcy and we
were able to talk about that and the
great thing I was able to have a
dialogue with these kids like if I was
directing adults and they were able to
take all this and be able to bring that
out into scenes and and really make it
feel so textural and be able to put
what's what's behind the words so that
was that boot camp that we set up and
always down to skateboarding you know
consulting for skateboarding
learning about for Pete you know Mom did
on meth and for mr. on heroin the
parents were great and helped having me
have the the complete time to have time
to really understand these different
events so it was a big process I was
talking to a lot of the younger kids and
we were talking they just keep moving no
matter how tough it is they don't really
think about the situation of the
addiction or the just ideal of crime the
ideal if you got a run from the housing
authorities some of the housing 30
police officers are not some of the
nicest guys constant break-ins it's
really we felt like we were joking we
said let's like almost home alone you
know and that's what they were their
home along and they have to survive so
the filmmaker you just sometimes you
just as a kid you just learn from that
that sometimes you just stay in the
moment don't think about the obstacles
ahead don't think about the past
mistakes just think about the moment and
ask why mister is able to reach out to
his mom and forgive them forgive her at
that time and for you guys I know that
either dance for martial arts that you
guys have studied the physicality of
that did that help you get to the
authentic portrayals that that Georgia
was talking about like the way that
people move across the screen and things
like that do you guys think that your
training and that helped you training in
dance for me definitely running
I'm running in a movie running up the
stairs running from the cops running
period for me yes yes the running is my
martial arts really help me with that
because we have to do laps like I think
like with the exercises every day before
we get into our are our moves or
whatever and I think Mars just kind of
made me tougher in this movie you know
it's a I'm sure it's an ordeal just
getting getting the movie done and and
for you - what have you found since I
know you mentioned Jimmy Kimmel you're
on the Jimmy Kimmel show that's crazy
like when you walk out it's like tons of
people and care but it was definitely
experience I think for both of us and
you know it was so much fun you know
talking to Jimmy and I'm just looking at
the audience for me he's like he's Jimmy
Kimmel stepped off the TV strain for me
I you know you get to see things that
you think are on TV like when you watch
TV come on in the background I thought
it was a window but it's basically just
a painting and the guests they I thought
they walk out of an elevator it's just a
door that goes up with this and the
traffic you really have to wonder what
what this whole Hollywood thing is
really about I mean I'm a big music fan
I remember talking to you before about
music some great music in this was there
a song that you were particularly happy
to get for the soundtrack of the score
yeah you know originally there's a song
that Jennifer Hudson character listens
to every time and originally there was a
whole an old song called
you know she's gone in the script so it
was an awesome song and I was like I
love how all the notes and I wanted to
get in touch with them at some point
actually we did and he was able to make
some room availability for us to use the
song but we got an editing room the way
we shot the movie the tone being in New
York had been in an environment that
song just didn't fit
by chance my editor put in old his
reading which is my father grew up being
in Milwaukee my father's also collector
of music Otis Redding just fit that's
one thing I like to save to filmmakers
is that if you have any problem just put
on the oldest reading something that
works with a lot of things he will work
for everything